What can I do for you?
Well I'm calling to book a table for four people,...
...and also I'd like to ask you a few questions.
Certainly, sir. What do you need to know?
Well, what are your opening hours?
Our restaurant is open from Tuesday to Sunday.
We're closed on Mondays.
And is there a car park?
Yes, the car park is at the back of the restaurant.
Great, and what time do you serve lunch?
We serve lunch from 12:00 to 2:30.
From 12:00 to 2:30.
Well, then I'd like to make a reservation then.
Certainly sir. When for?
For this coming Sunday.
Lunchtime or evening?
For lunch. We'll be coming around 1 o'clock.
One o'clock. OK.
For how many people?
For four.
Very well, sir.
What's the name please?
Monaghan.
Could you spell that, please?
Yeah. M O N A G H A N.
Alright Mr. Monaghan, one table for four for Sunday, 1:00 p.m.
Yeah, that's great.